we miss you won't next time our blasters
are useless against him hey let's make
the baby do the magic hands come on baby
do the magic hand thing
I'm out of ideas I'm not
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Mandalorian episode eight
video amazing episode but it's also the
season 1 finale so I'll explain what's
happening next they're already in the
middle of shooting season 2 right now
we'll break it all down be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos if
you're brand new to the channel
obviously careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet we'll do
top 10 WTF and easter eggs as we go
along starting with number 10 the scout
troopers who picked up baby Yoda are
heading back into town one of them is
Adam pally who we met in last week's
episode he was the one that was trying
to buy the Mandalorians helmet for 12
credits but I don't know if they did
this in the last week's episode but the
other stormtrooper the one that has baby
Yoda in the pouch is actually played by
Jason Sudeikis from Saturday Night Live
you probably recognize his voice a
little bit and he probably seen him in a
billion other things by now he was also
the one that bopped baby Yoda on the
head when he started cooing really loud
they bring back that old but classic
joke about stormtroopers not being able
to hit the broadside of a barn with
their blasters even at point-blank range
they take a whole bunch of shots to that
object on the ground and miss every
single time the thing I really
appreciate about the way they pull this
joke off is the fact that neither one
refers to how bad the other one is with
a blaster they just keep trying to hit
it and failing they make a couple
references to moth Kitty in killing his
own men first with the death troopers in
last week's episode then just a couple
moments later they also say that he just
killed another officer for interrupting
him during his big speechifying moment
while he was talking to everyone inside
the cantina that's just a classic Darth
Vader reference killing your own
officers at every turn because they're
incompetent or they interrupt you or
they just piss you off there are a
couple more funny moments before IG 11
shows up baby Oda bites Adam Polly's
finger when he tries to poke it inside
the bag the actual title of the episode
though is Redemption that's a reference
to IG 11 storyline redeeming himself for
trying to kill baby Yoda in episode 1
and also the Mandalorians storyline
redeeming himself for his checkered past
as a bounty hunter
so number 9 IG 11 springs into action to
save baby Yoda because it's part of his
base programming to be basically a nanny
droid and take care of him he tells a
couple jokes while he's busy wrecking
those scout troopers then he takes off
on one of their speeder bikes with baby
Yoda back into town
back in town Moff Gideon rolls out the e
Webb repeating heavy blaster to take
them out inside the cantina that's
a reference to Empire Strikes Back that
was one of the first times we actually
saw one of those weapons but they
basically used this scene to narrate
everyone's full backstory reveal pretty
much most of the secrets that you didn't
know before where everyone comes from
the Mandalorian also reveals how he
knows who bought Gideon is so number
eight everyone's backstories
starting with Kara dune we learned that
her real name is Cara Cynthia dune even
though she was a rebel shock trooper
before that she is actually from
Alderaan so is blown up so that's
probably one of the reasons why she
joined the rebellion we find out the
Mandalorians real name is din Joran Moff
Gideon also makes a reference to the
siege of Mandalore the night of a
thousand tears that's an event that's
going to be covered during the Clone
Wars season seven episodes that will air
in February on Disney plus but the whole
thing here is the Dave Filoni who's an
executive producer it has a lot of
creative control over the Mandalorian
live-action series also did the Clone
Wars series so it makes sense that he
would try to tie some of the events on
the live-action series with the animated
series that's getting ready to premiere
and I will do Easter eggs for those
Clone Wars episodes in February when
they do drop so just mark your calendars
for that they don't say a whole lot
about grief cargas backstory they just
say disgrace and magistrate but Carl
Weathers did say that they would get
more into his backstory during season
two they're in the middle of filming
that right now so we'll learn more about
him next season when they're trying to
figure out what to do next Cara Doon
worries that she's going to be uploaded
to a mind flayer that's one of the
creatures from rogue one that they
connected to the Imperial pilot too it
just sucked the information right out of
him but then as the Mandalorians starts
remembering the events of the Clone Wars
and how Moff Gideon could have all this
information the fact that he was on
Mandalore during the siege of Mandalore
he starts flashing back so number seven
the Mandalorians flash back to the Clone
Wars in attack of the clones we get a
much more complete version of his
flashback to his childhood in his
village when the battle droids from the
separatists army come to attack they
kill his parents right after they stuff
him in that cell earth and just as the
battle droid is getting ready to kill
him another Mandalorian we don't know
who it is it's just a random Mandalorian
comes to save him
they start playing the Mandalorian theme
song from the end of episode 3 when the
other Mandalorians from his clan came to
save him it is basically a version of
that said in the past the Mandalorian
that saved him carries him off in his
jet pack and he explains in present day
what it is
to be a foundling and how he was raised
by them I was raised in there fighting
court treated the same as any other
Mandalorian and when I came of age I was
sworn to the Creed because this is the
way this would have meant to be the
moment when he puts the helmet on you
will never take this off in the presence
of another person although I know
there's a lot of questions about this
because during the Clone Wars animated
series in Star Wars rebels there are
Mandalorians that take their helmets off
all the time so I'm assuming that this
rule started sometime after the events
of those series the reason why he
remembers Moff Gideon makes that
connection is because he could have only
gotten the information on his family
name from Mandalore when he says Gideon
was a member of the IASB that's the
Imperial Security Bureau they're a law
enforcement and security branch of the
Empire we saw a bunch of them in the
white uniforms on Scarab when they went
to steal the plans for the Death Star
number six WTF IG 11 shoots his way into
town with baby Oda in tow to save
everyone baby Yoda just laughing the
whole way through like he's super
excited about what's going on like oh
yeah another adventure I get to go on I
also love all this is happening grief
carga just keeps taking shots because
they're still inside the cantina there's
still all that booze that wasn't blown
up when the death troopers blew a hole
in the wall just needs a little liquid
courage to get him through the rest of
the day
RG 11 is able to distract the
stormtroopers just enough so they can
get outside and start blasting them
themselves it turns into this big
shootout remember the Mandalorian series
is inspired by classic westerns and
samurai films so of course there's gonna
be a big shootout in the finale the
Mandalorian uses the same trick that he
used from Episode one there are a lot of
callbacks to the first episode too
particularly because of what happens
with IG 11s droid during the episode but
he does the same thing that he did with
the giant quote-unquote Gatling gun from
episode one now this is Star Wars so
they're heavy blasters but
metaphorically it's meant to be their
version of an Old West Gatling gun so he
picks it up it just starts using it to
mow through all of the other
stormtroopers you could kind of tell
early in the episode that they're trying
to let you know that Moff Gideon isn't
your typical incompetent stormtrooper
he's actually very smart so he knows to
blow up the Power Cell to get rid of the
Mandalorian Early's disable him for a
while they're trying to set him up as a
credible threat in the future so they
don't want to make too much of a mockery
of him in this episode even though the
Mandalorian is eventually able to take
him down his actions let you know that
he is very calculating and smart
he is a survivor just like the
Mandalorian is but he's hurt bad he
thinks he's gonna die he won't let them
take his helmet off because this is the
way but gives them his sigil Mandalorian
pendants has give this to the other
Mandalorians tell them that I sent you
they literally and metaphorically jump
out of the fire into the frying pan
because Moff Gideon sends in a flame
trooper to just burn them out of the
cantina but number five WTF baby Yoda
saves them using the force he winds up
barbecuing that flame trooper but then
he just completely passes out from the
effort just because it took so much out
of him
but he's back again pretty quickly but
that's the reason why he couldn't just
Forge healed the Mandalorian and it had
to be IG 11 with the bhakta spray they
make a real big deal after everyone gets
into the sewer about him taking his
helmet off I'm not a living being you're
not violating your Creed by letting me
see your face in the only way we're
gonna save you is if you do take that
helmet off I think we'd all assumed that
we were gonna see him without his helmet
off before the end of the season but
initially I'd assumed that he would just
do it for baby Yoda because the armor
kind of made it official that he's
really baby Yoda's father for the time
being till he comes of age at least or
they find other Jedi or other members of
his race that can care for him so within
the rules of their Creed you are allowed
to take your helmet off with members of
your direct family like if you're
married to someone or you had children
you could take your helmet off in front
of them but to go back into the sewers
Ninja Turtle style and number four big
WTF he finds all of his former
Mandalorian clan mates are dead their
helmets in a pile only the armor has
survived although technically she did
say maybe some were able to get off
planet it's really messed up like this
one belonged to jon favreau the member
of the vizla family i believe his name
was paz vizla in the credits oh it just
means he was a member of house vizla
which was a big callback to jon favreau
playing the pre vizla character during
the Clone Wars so jon favreau himself
played this character but I think part
of the idea of getting rid of some of
these characters that it takes a crutch
away from them because if they can swoop
in and save you anytime you need them
then it kind of takes some of the
tension out of the episodes and also Jon
Favreau isn't gonna show up in every
single episode like they got rid of Tyco
what td's character IG 11 because Tyco a
TD isn't gonna be around to be in
episodes all the time in the future
either so they get rid of them for
thematic reasons but also for practical
reasons by the logic of the episode the
way the
muhr explains it the reason why they're
dead is because after the events of
Episode three
they basically outed themselves
Imperials are former Imperials found out
about it and they eventually came back
to take care of them because the whole
concept of them being in the sewers as
they were trying to stay off the radar
so that the empire wouldn't find out
about them or the remnants of the empire
she meets baby Yoda formally and charges
the Mandalorian with training him
protecting him and reuniting him with
his own kind naming him a member of his
clan calling him a foundling just like
the Mandalorian was when he was a child
in the fact that he's wearing that
pendant at the end of the episode like
you know what you keep that you keep
wearing that also kind of means like
they think of baby Yoda now is another
Mandalorian they made a whole big thing
earlier in the episode saying that the
Mandalorians aren't a race they're a
creed so any member of another race can
become a Mandalorian as long as they
take that creed so was like saying that
baby Oda is going to be another
Mandalorian you have to picture him with
like a tiny little band delorean helmet
on his head and you betcha
Disney is probably thinking about
merchandising a version of baby Yoda
with Mandalorian armor on him the real
big thing that happens here though is
that she gives him his signet he's
earned it because of his actions
protecting baby Yoda and his new charge
in his mission to find his people if he
couldn't make this out before it's
actually meant to be the face of the mud
horn because as this giant horn on it
was just a reference to baby Yoda saving
him and him saving baby Yoda but also
taking down this giant beast but that's
what it's gonna look like I'm sure
they'll start selling merchandise with
that symbol on it pretty soon too as
they start to leave the last thing that
she gives him is a shiny new jet pack
paying off the reference from episode 3
I gotta get me one of those the formal
name that she refers to it as is the
rising phoenix you have trained in the
rising phoenix yes well you'll need to
practice with it again or it will not
obey your commands they have a really
badass fight scene with her later in the
episode just to let you know that she
can back up all this hardcore talk that
she's spitting out she was also
basically the leader of their clan and
because there's such a military marshal
like society usually the leaders wind up
being some of the fiercest fighters
there's a big episode 3 Revenge of the
Sith Mustafar reference when they go to
the lava flow the lava river that takes
them
to outside I was a little disappointed
that nobody made a reference to the
stormtroopers having the high ground
there's another r2 unit this is a fairy
droid but they make a big joke about it
being super super tall because every
time you see an r2 unit you'd expect it
to be really really tiny the number 3 IG
11 sacrifices himself using his self
destruct mechanism to save everyone it's
another big callback to the first
episode because he tried several times
during the end of that episode to blow
himself up I cannot be captured I must
activate my self-destruct this is also
part of his Redemption like the title of
the episode is redemption so it's a lot
about what IG 11 does in the episode to
redeem himself but the Mandalorian is
also redeeming himself too for his past
even baby Yoda kind of seems sad to see
him go like he's watching it all this
zoom in on his face like I was only with
you for a little while I understand that
you used to try to kill me but now I
kind of care about you Moff Gideon shows
up in his Thai fighter to get them grief
carga makes a joke about the magic hand
thing candy do his magic hand thing even
baby oda kind of waves his hand a little
bit understanding what he's talking
about the number two the Mandalorian
uses his new jetpack the rising phoenix
to take down Moff Gideon's TIE fighter
but it was a badass takedown move you
actually saw this scene during the
season 1 trailer that's how far long
they were in production when they
released that trailer they used this
last couple scenes to set up what the
characters gonna be doing when we head
into season 2 grief carga is gonna stay
on navarro cara dune so that she's gonna
stay behind to to make sure all the
Imperials are gone he formally offers
her membership in the bounty hunters
guild as his enforcer and says that when
she does join he'll take care of her
chain code so that there won't be a
bounty on her head anymore the reason
why there's still a bounty on her head
is because she's a New Republic deserter
so they're gonna take care of that once
she joins the guild grief cargo drops a
sly obi-wan Kenobi referenced when he
says all the scum and villainy are gone
the line was all about obi-wan Kenobi
explaining moss eisely he says you will
never find a more wretched hive of scum
and villainy the Mandalorian says that
he's going to be busy trying to find
other Jedi and members of Yoda's race to
take care of baby Yoda the way they talk
about the Jedi during the episode with
the armor is kind of funny too because
she makes references to them as
sorcerers that fought with the ancient
great Mandalore they're talking about
the ancient Jedi wars with the
Mandalorian people that was thousands of
years ago when the Mandalorians
controlled
the planets in this sector of space
called the Mandalorian sector it was
right down here a little bit further
south in the galaxy cluster he buries
quill gives baby Yoda his sigil pendant
or at least lets him keep it he finds an
item oh I never thought I'd see that
again you know what you hang on to that
that's just another metaphor that baby
Oda is now considered to be a
Mandalorian as per their Creed but then
because you have to have that tag seen
at the end
number one the dark saber ending scene
in the season 2 teaser so in the tag
scene at the end the Jawas come to pick
apart Moff Gideon's TIE fighter just
another callback to episode 2 when the
other jaw was on that other planet
picked apart the razor crest but all of
a sudden he starts cutting himself out
of the wreckage with the dark saber the
minute that it punctured right through
the hole I knew instantly what that was
I was oh my gosh I can't believe they're
actually doing a live-action version of
the dark saber finally because of what
the Mandalorian revealed about Moff
Gideon's past in the siege of Mandalore
I think it's assumed that Moff Gideon
probably stole that during the siege of
Mandalore the last time we actually saw
it in an official Canon Star Wars series
was during Star Wars rebels at the end
and it was Bo Catan Crees played by
Katee Sackhoff who was uniting the
Mandalorian clans again that was all
taking place before a new hope so
obviously I think the great purge
happens sometime during the course of
the original trilogy so sometime between
then in Return of the Jedi is probably
when Moff Gideon acquired the dark saber
but I will do a separate video all about
the dark saber and all about season 2
stuff they're about halfway done filming
right now so we won't have to wait too
long before they give us some footage if
you spotted any other big Easter eggs or
references during the episode that I
didn't mention in the video just write
them below in the comments and like I
said I will be doing the Clone Wars
Easter egg episodes but those won't
start happening till February I'll just
remind people when they drop another
trailer I'll be posting more Mandalorian
this weekend more which are Netflix
videos while you wait for all that click
here for my video about where baby Oda
was during the rise of Skywalker and
click here for all my Mandalorian
episodes thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome this is the way I
have spoken
[Music]